hello guys and happy I don't know what
day it is honestly all right so when
living in a world where you have a job
where you work 40 hours a week sometimes
your job calls on you to render under
Caesar
yeah I have a full-time job and you do
what that means that sometimes your job
will call on you to do so my job is
called on me to help them out for the
next couple weeks so they flew me two
states away to utilize my skills mad
skills I think which is funny because
when I'm working 12-hour days I'm really
good like I have really good work ethic
for the first about eight hours after
that I hit the wall about is useful as a
work on Iraq and do rocks get
warts I don't think so but it sounds
pretty useless don't it this guy after
about nine hours of work plus the nurses
check there she's pretty cute she's on
it so after eight or nine hours I was
like what to do let's hit on her why not
I'm there so I'm hitting on this girl
I'm flirting with her she's pretty fun
my boss sees it he's like hey
why don't you hang clocks but I
understand why he did it because I mean
I was utilizing all aspects of the
American dream chasing ass at work and
so I want to publicly apologize to my
work about that it doesn't mean I won't
do it tomorrow fact is a guarantee I
will absolutely do it tomorrow she's hot
and pretty fun I think but I was like I
ain't going unless I can bring the
laptop and the camera got it do the
videos got to entertain the people which
is funny because when you go on a plane
and you bring a camera a laptop a laptop
cord an XLR cable a Nintendo DS
headphones and a microphone and they run
it under the x-ray machine I'm pretty
sure it looks something like this so
they did the whole open the bag please I
don't know if anchor I totally do this -
so I got checked out it's fine here we
are with all my gear but what I'm trying
to say is this weekend I won't be able
to bring you guys movie reviews next
weekend more hopeful and there's
actually a possibility of me screening
the movie really early but if I do get
to bring you movie reviews I'll be in
this hotel that looks like my grandma's
bedroom and how I'd know what that looks
like nice hotel though they did set me
up with that and I absolutely plan to
make classic movie reviews that I would
release sequentially while I'm down here
but getting to you reviewers Movie
Awards together hook up every minute of
all of my time for the entire week but I
wanted to let you guys know what the
next couple weeks is gonna be like we'll
try to get you movie reviews as soon as
possible in the meantime we will talk
about a lot of other in the world
of entertainment still a lot of to
talk about in the world you know how the
world is and for your pleasure in the
meantime here are some of my favorite
vids say you can entertain yourself with
for the day and they are
you